there was another strike on viv  according to preliminary information  there were four hits  three of them went to  warehouses which were not used by the  military  so far and there was one hit  on a garage  which was providing maintenance for  uh vehicles seven  killed eleven injured  it's a barbaric strike it's a civilian  object people were there  working  unfortunately  the tragedy  has happened on the other hand maybe it  was a deliberate strike on the civilian  facility  because there's nothing sacred for them  [Music]  now in ukraine there are no safe and  unsafe locations  everyone is in the same condition so  once again i reiterate  uh  my call to all the residents whenever  you hear a siren please  go to shelters because it might save  a